[Musica]
quando siete incappati l'ultima volta in
una clamorosa fake news
pensateci a me e credo a molti di voi è
successo sul finire dell'estate scorsa
quando suo malgrado una modella si è
trovata al centro appunto di una fec
news
andiamo con ordine la modella ha sfilato
per gucci nel settembre del 2019 e è
sparita dalle scene
il primo agosto del 2020
quindi undici mesi dopo è ritornata sul
palcoscenico potremmo dire questa volta
su però sul palcoscenico mediatico e non
su una passerella infatti il primo
agosto del 2020 su un portale web
polacco è comparso un min su cui la
modella in questione è stata presentata
da gucci stesso come una delle 100
modelle più sexy del mondo
qualche tempo dopo il 20 agosto del 2020
lo stesso man
tradotto in italiano è comparso sui
portali sui portali della nostra nazione
e a quel punto la modella è stata
addirittura presentata come non una
delle 100 modelli più sexy del mondo
da gucci ma la una delle 100 donne più
belle del mondo
secondo il giudizio dello stesso
alessandro michele che ha il creativo il
direttore creativo di gucci
ora come in un crescendo rossiniano don
basilio nel barbiere di siviglia canta
che la calunnia è un venticello piano
piano venticello avete capito sia sempre
più ingrandito ed è sfociata addirittura
in una campagna di body shiming questo
perché se anche si riesce a smascherare
in fretta una feki news
perché di una tecnica si tratta la fit
news può creare dei danni
spieghiamo perché è una freak news lo
stesso alessandro michele l'ufficio
stampa di gucci ha dichiarato che mai
nessuno ha stilato quella classifica
ma neppure il brand il brand gucci
dunque una fec news nel giro di poco
meno di una settimana si è trasformata
in una vera campagna di odio di chef
body shiming abbiamo detto al cui centro
si è trovato suo malgrado è la modella
ora non so se avete mai pensato o avete
mai riflettuto su quanto dolore possa
provocare una campagna di questo tipo su
chi ne è vittima
a me è capitato e probabilmente questo è
per deformazione professionale
io sono un insegnante delle scuole
secondarie di secondo grado dunque mio
compito oltre quello di istruire è ancor
più quello di educare gli adolescenti e
lo sapete gli adolescenti vivono un
momento delicato della loro vita
un momento denso di problemi di dubbi e
soprattutto questo è causato proprio
dalla risonanze psicologiche del mutato
rapporto tra il proprio corpo e la
percezione del proprio corpo degli
adolescenti e non di rado purtroppo a
scuola lo viviamo non dico
quotidianamente ma quasi ci troviamo di
fronte anche a ragazzini che non
accettano il proprio corpo soprattutto
in riferimento a quelli che la società
considera come modelli vincenti modelli
validi
ora questo perché l'individualità di
ognuno di noi si crea nel confronto con
gli altri
la nostra individualità non la
costruiamo da solo da soli sono gli
altri che ci aiutano a crearla
immaginate allora un ragazzino di 14 15
16 anni vittima di bullismo come
potrebbe essere in questo caso che
arriva come dice la formula stessa
inglese a vergognarsi del proprio corpo
ora ripeto io sono un insegnante nel
caso specifico un insegnante di storia
dell'arte dunque è alle arti visive che
mi sono rivolto per tentare di parlare
con le mie ragazze e i miei ragazzi di
questo problema concentrandomi su una
domanda la domanda è esiste la bellezza
con la b maiuscola ma arco
ancor meglio esistono modelli di
bellezza femminile e maschile sempre
validi univoci ora avrete capito da
quello che ho detto prima che i modelli
servono per formarsi e quindi ci siamo
passati tutti abbiamo tutti avuto
qualcuno qualcosa a cui far riferimento
ora partendo appunto dalle arti visive
siano pittura scultura fotografia ma
anche immagini pubblicitarie una
rapidissima scorsa ci può far dire già
una prima cosa se per il corpo maschile
tutto sommato quello che piaceva gli
antichi greci piace anche a noi e questo
lo possiamo vedere con un rapidissimo
confronto muovendoci dall'arte antica
col doriforo di policleto all'arte
moderna col david di michelangelo a un
modello che qualche anno fa sfilato per
dolce gabbana e è stato protagonista di
un loro calendario ecco diremmo che è
chiaro quello che ho appena affermato se
ci spostiamo invece nell'ambito
femminile ben più bastano poche immagini
anche qui in senso cronologico partendo
dall'antica grecia con una statua della
venere accovacciata dalle forme morbide
abbondanti che sono le stesse che si
ritrovano poi in queste tre grazie
dipinte nel xvii secolo da rubens
ecco fino al xvii secolo ma potremmo
andare anche più avanti potremmo dire
che il modello femminile non è cambiato
se guardiamo quelli che quelli che hanno
la mia età ricordano come le super top
della fine degli anni 80 inizio anni 90
vediamo invece come sia mutato ed è
fortemente mutato
potremmo dire che quello che piace a noi
forse non sarebbe piaciuto rubens è
sicuramente quello che piaceva a rubens
non piace a noi
qui però potremo aprire tantissimi
tantissimi tasselli mi faccio riflettere
soltanto una cosa noi oggi abbiamo
chiaro un concetto l'eccesso di peso
l'adipe è un problema perché crea
problemi a livelli di salute per cui per
noi
magro non è solo bello
ma anche sano e potremmo anche fare
riferimenti al bello e il buono degli
antichi greci lachapelle andando avanti
però se anzi tornando indietro e cioè
tornando alla rubens le cose per
all'epoca era diverso
non tutti anzi la maggior parte delle
persone non erano in grado non potevano
nutrirsi adeguatamente correttamente
come noi potremmo fare
e voi sapete che il corpo femminile al
di sotto di una percentuale di grasso
corporeo blocca il ciclo mestruale
quindi una donna troppo magra denutrita
non potrebbe non potrebbe procreare ecco
perché le tre grazie che di cui vi ho
appena parlato ma ancor più questa che è
addirittura la moglie di rubens è
rappresentata con queste forme e se
guardate il particolare delle ginocchia
sembra che quasi che ruby si sia voluto
concentrare sulla cellulite orrore per
noi oggi che all'epoca invece era a
segno di buona e buona salute
allora queste poche immagini ci hanno
dimostrato come nel caso della donna per
i motivi che vi ho detto
il concetto di bello corporeo sia
profondamente cambiato ma se torniamo da
dove siamo partiti
ovvero alle sfilate al mondo della moda
in questo caso è ancora voci ma avrei
potuto parlare anche di altre altri
stilisti di altri brand vediamo che
anche nel caso del corpo maschile
le cose stanno cambiando in realtà ormai
più di una decina d'anni che sono
soltanto che abbiano in questo senso
ora se guardi se confrontiamo queste
immagini con quelle che abbiamo guardato
prima qui vediamo un corpo maschile
completamente diverso anche per quello
che riguarda i tratti dei volti cosa
vuole dirci alessandro michele
probabilmente il messaggio è che è
inutile parlare di un concetto unico di
bellezza perché non esiste quello che va
bene oggi non andrà bene domani quello
che piace oggi non piace una volta potrà
piacere in futuro forse no dunque la
conclusione
esistono tanti modelli tanti esempi
tanti canoni di bellezza maschile e
femminile quanti sono le culture che li
hanno prodotti vi faccio anche
riflettere su un'ultima questione ci
siamo riferiti soltanto al mondo
occidentale in questo caso la moda è
emblematica in quanto è la moda
occidentale e quella che si è imposta in
tutto in tutto il mondo dunque anche in
asia anche in india i modelli sono
questi perché questa è la società
occidentale
pubblicità ma evidentemente pensando ad
altre culture potremmo aprire tantissimi
altri
altri discorsi ora se facciamo ancora
riferimento alle arti visive e prendiamo
come esempio dipinti e fotografie
vediamo che in realtà l'arte aveva già
anticipato questo concetto
i pittori espressionisti hanno
rappresentato i tratti dei volti ei
corpi dei loro modelli secondo un
procedimento di deformazione addirittura
è sicuramente questi che noi oggi non
esiteremmo definire dei bei dipinti nel
momento in cui sono stati realizzati non
sono stati percepiti come tali
se però facciamo riferimento alla
marchesa casati qualche decennio dopo
siamo proprio nei primi due decenni del
novecento ecco quella donna ha fatto
girare la testa a mezza europa allo
stesso d'annunzio che era dedicato un
opera teatrale e arrivando a tempi
ancora più vicine a noi pedro almodovar
ha preso come sua musa una delle sue
muse ispiratrici rossy de palma che è
stata definita da ma picasso per le
proporzioni e soprattutto gli spigoli
potremmo dire proprio che si colgono sul
suo volto ecco allora che ancora una
volta l'arte ci dimostra quello di cui
vi ho parlato
vi voglio lasciare con una conclusione
partendo insegna liceo scientifico
linguistico di cesena da una riflessione
lessicale e quanto è labile diciamo così
il concetto di bellezza anche proprio
pensando alle parole noi italiani
usiamo la parola bello per descrivere
sia la bellezza fisica di una persona ma
anche per parlare di una cosa diciamo
che è bello è bello una cosa o una
persona bello è una parola che deriva
dal latino dal latino medievale non dal
latino classico
ora se ci spostiamo ad esempio in spagna
per definire la bellezza fisica
in spagna si usano altre parole guapo
lindo oppure hermoso hermoso deriva dal
latino formose
ecco anche nel caso del latino formoso
era una parola che si usava
soprattutto per descrivere la bellezza
maschile mentre per una donna si sarebbe
più opportunamente utilizzato il termine
pulchra dare dire a un legionario oa un
gladiatore che era pulcher non sarebbe
stato un complimento e quindi qui
vediamo come di nuovo si torna a
differenziare uomo donna
se poi dalla spagna passiamo alla
germania in tedesco bello si dice shore
che fa riferimento allo splendore del
sole quindi a un campo semantico
completamente diverso da quello che
abbiamo utilizzato fino adesso ora come
può esserci un unico idea di bellezza se
anche solo limitandosi alla nostra
europa le lingue descrivono la bellezza
contante del contante accezioni diverse
provo a salutarvi e a lasciarvi con una
riflessione
potremmo passare a utilizzare un termine
diverso allontanare quello di bellezza
che abbiamo visto non è univoco e
concentrarsi invece su un altro termine
che è quello di armonia
ecco sul concetto di armonia forse se si
potrebbe trovare più d'accordo armonia
intesa come proporzione fra le parti
come armonia tra il dettaglio è
l'insieme è a questo aggiungere la
definizione che di bello dava la
filosofia scolastica bellum est quod
viso un placet che non è il
semplicistico il proverbiale non è bello
ciò che è bello ma è bello ciò che piace
quanto è bello ciò che visto e cioè
conosciuto vedere implica il conoscere
piace
ora se uniamo queste due cose io credo
potremo trovare una soluzione
la conoscenza sono un insegnante è
quello che ci può permettere
innanzitutto di smascherare delle flash
news e poi di evitare quindi di sfociare
in inutili e dolorose campagne di body
scemi e magari riuscire a trovare non
bello ma armonioso anche un volto come
quello della modella
di gucci grazie